walk him to this video when playing
flying donkey flying donkey the CFO
named Bobby Chiang okay Bobby Cheng his
name rings a bell I did not do not quite
sure what Bell I think it isn't this a
guy who recently want some tournament is
this a source Australia mm not sure
there was something okay let's see we
have got a modern defense IAM and many
possible ways to play against that this
9797 set up a something that i had
studied in the past and never really am
could could make it work to always
looked a bit tricky for black and this H
pawn push yourself is one way to play
it's yeah that's so it's just it's just
not much fun to defend against the
opening age file it's not it's not
terribly bad for black but I never
really considered this to be worth
investigating in more detail let's see
um 22 yeah and I probably need to need
to prepare long castle anyway yeah it's
not like and I'm just meeting him here
with the H file open it says it's not so
easy but it's certainly not much fun for
black okay so I'm putting some pressure
on your phone should I go f3 yeah I
probably should
yeah there's no no way to play without
it I guess how interesting so black is
trying to gain some control over the
dark squares here so I should probably
take it young or night be 3 or 9292
actually I alike yeah let's do that
right b3 is going to play if I therefore
it's not not helping they don't want to
help them develop with the night x e6
you know what to what's my play I was
really expecting that he should he know
he needs to do something drastic like b5
that some nothing I can do against that
without long castling I cannot play
anyway okay well it can I can ignore it
for the moment if he takes Bishop takes
activates my bishop be 495 is also fine
so I probably should go here and try to
get rid of the bishop id-5 is a
self-made so not not advisable let's
just take it okay and turn how to how to
proceed here now night I'd like to go 95
here and what else is there i can go g45
now ok g4g 595 f6 you know this is some
a simple plan
it's weakening the dark squares though
I'm not sure maybe I should have thought
about this a bit longer okay well g5 is
not good you 2nite III to f5 this is
probably oh he's going for that I
thought this would be would be just just
too too loose yes that's a good square
but still I don't I don't believe it
there's also this myth just asking black
how how are you going to to defend a c7
and this rook h5 also should i just play
that rook age five and look aged 54
gauge one I don't don't see much count
to play a really let's do that
you can never take on d5 to to see txt 5
this is a just unplayable ok I know I
can I could play book h8 and take on f6
at the end now that's pretty good
actually check because the pain is
default g5 hanging at the end this King
is still terribly weak
ok
that's not can take here but I don't
have a direct win strangely enough check
10 in 27 here
want to keep f3 where's Jackie
brooksy 896 check very important of
course re5 maybe was good time morning
check check check I sent them made
somewhere I don't believe that here
Chang have six even that is not a mate
amazingly enough check
check
check check check no the Queen no ah the
damn rukon age three yeah come on ah
white resigns all right this will hurt
probably i have multiple mates and stuff
if I and I came only five plus 10 and so
on yeah lemme just winning with every
move check problem check that simply
didn't didn't find the killer queen bee
500k that's not so yeah but this is
probably also when yeah right see Sammy
is a complete win g 596 and Quincy five
vs is a maid Union check this is a maid
check the iron up winning up just
winning or rooks him check aah chak now
this is also jang actually I just I just
didn't see the roof I just didn't see
the rock yeah this is check this is
another win and he's overloaded or what
what else yeah yeah a bit of a shame I
mean it was it was a very one-sided game
and simply blundered the Queen at the
end check maybe maybe I had something
better along the way this is possible
yeah well this is this is winning but I
was Luke age 7 it's even stronger yeah
this is this this is much easier
actually
and no move if he takes you know I
should have spent a Cabot it just just
the kind of knock out that ends the game
immediately woke aged seven no no this
is this is check super easy and this as
well you know all night at five I mean
it's it's just the ruined i mean like
had been completely outplayed him but it
doesn't help if you've done the coin in
jai time troll yeah it was so
interesting game nevertheless thanks for
watching